dear colleagues dear friends i am
honored to address you at the kickoff of
this new edition of the startup prize
for mobility
accessibility is an enabler of rights
autonomy and equality it is a
precondition for the full participation
of persons with disabilities in society
but for many traveling remains a
challenge due to a lack of accessibility
or assistance
removing these barriers is a cornerstone
of the european commission's efforts to
create a union of equality
this is why the special prize for
accessibility and inclusive mobility to
be awarded in this new edition is
important technological developments
have led to new mobility options and now
it is time to turn the focus on
inclusion so that persons with
disabilities can equally enjoy the
benefits of these new solutions
we need to strengthen existing startups
in this growing sector and inspire the
creation of new ones
innovation should leave no one behind
this is all the more important in our
aging societies a number of eu rules are
in place to make the eu more accessible
last year we launched the sustainable
and smart mobility strategy this year we
will review the rules of passengers
rights and non-intelligence transport
systems to make transport services
accessible for all
over the next decade further progress
will be achieved with our new strategy
for the rights of persons with
disabilities for instance next year we
will set up accessible eu a european
resource center offering also
opportunities to showcase innovation for
accessible mobility
and european commission continues to
reward the efforts of cities across
europe that make their environment more
accessible
with this new special prize for
accessibility and inclusive mobility we
want to showcase solutions that give
better independence and autonomy to
people and smart cities
provide equal access to transportation
services and address social exclusion
i encourage you to join this contest be
a game changer for accessible and
inclusive mobility to build a
barrier-free europe we need you and your
ideas